and
does tim pool count i'm going to use 10
plus
i mean
i wanted to give somebody that people
would hate
and i know
you don't
have you don't have anything against
anybody like actually but you know oh
god
like this video if you haven't liked it
has to be those three
yeah okay honestly it's a game you have
to put somebody in a category
i
would probably
five
i would i would i would marry
um
rolo probably he's got a wife okay okay
well these are my three i would probably
i'm gonna
myron and kill tim pool just because i
don't
i'm so not gonna age well but i love it
okay you can play you can do it
backwards okay um you do
hi dad
um
okay
um
do
rolo
okay um
uh fresh okay and
donovan this is like really uncool
okay
no offense donovan but i would kill you
if we were married so
i'm kidding
probably
[ __ ] rolo that sounds weird
f rolo
merry
fresh
um
see i would say mary rollo he's very
tolerable i don't know
but like he has a wife actually i would
marry
in this situation they're single like
you don't have to think about it oh then
i'd marry rolo for sure
yeah cause i get everything i'm kidding
uh and then kill
i'm killing donovan
and then
what's the other one f or yeah i guess
i'm fn fresh
right
we both got stutter since okay
all right so now hold on
who said stop the cap
that was as honest as if
okay
hold on
is i can't see it i'm blind it's not bad
uh
are you putting them up on the screen
over there i won't be able to read it
lord
i'm getting him so blind now
okay who else okay tla
the lead attorney
uh
you know we gotta have diversity i'm
trying to think of a white one it's not
coming to my mind i'm kidding
if it's manosphere it's like okay oh uh
anthony dream johnson
who's that
anthony
i'm the president of the manosphere
anthony
21 studios let me let me look hold on 21
studios
i don't i don't know if i know
i might sometimes i know people's faces
i know i feel you this guy
no
okay
he looks like a woke boy 21 studios
anthony is his middle this is not gonna
age well it's okay
anthony dream
that's him you know him come on
uh not really
yeah you do i don't think i've ever he's
doxed everybody in the sphere okay yeah
i don't know who that is but i'll i'll
do it like i'll we'll i'll put him in
the three you know yeah yeah okay uh so
who else did i say tla okay him or jack
murphy
jack murphy
um he was just on you are here jack
murphy
this guy yeah
um okay that's oh this one's like my
eggs this one's easy um
if you knew the back story on
adj i think you would
the lead attorney i would marry
okay um he's he's so cute actually yeah
and then
this guy
i would probably have and then
this guy i would kill because okay you
gotta be specific anthony dream john i'm
sorry anthony dream johnson
and jack murphy you flipped it you
wanted to kill him no i wanted to kill
this guy no
but i don't i don't know though oh
god i just this the other guy was
younger like he's better looking
no
hair i'll show a goat that's is it not a
good picture it's a bad one okay
um i just uh look up oh actually is that
him yeah
oh let me flip it yeah
yeah let me flip it
okay good
um okay wait for you yeah kevin samuels
okay
um
the lead attorney okay
and
myron okay
i know myron is into like sister wives i
don't think i could do that
um
you know what i think i'd marry
this is a horrible lineup
tla
can i just like pick tla for all of them
i'm kidding no you're sorry they're
killing fine you know what i would
you know what i would marry myron
i would marry myron i'd feel sister
wives yeah okay
because i wouldn't have to deal with him
i'm kidding
no because i would feel safe with his
past work experience and that's
something that i really need if i'm
gonna marry somebody i have to feel safe
in a household
uh
i don't know about kevin samuels or tla
they just don't give me that vibe
not in a bad way
samuels i don't want to kill either
i guess i would kill tla
he he tries to run both sides of an
argument not in a bad way like
contradicts himself so you know what i
don't like that i ain't kidding
um and i guess what's up what that i
would f kevin samuels is that what you
said you'd kill him that's what you
could no
you
you kill the lead attorney nobody will
know wait so you're picking this based
on argue like their arguments no
i'm just picking whatever okay okay well
no i've met myron mm-hmm i would feel
safe with him i didn't speak to him that
much but he let me in this home so i'm
like fine
i don't want to kill anyone every human
life matters
i know but you're saying based on their
youtube channels like what
attorney based on like that he plays
both sides i couldn't come up with
anything okay yeah i don't want to kill
anybody but if if you do kill you have
to have a reason
no
girl that's
this game is rigged this is my show
okay tla is an attorney so of course he
has to analyze those sides
no comment
uh what's this um roo is this somebody
i'm ro
who's that
a-m-r-o-u that a name that you know i'm
sorry
a notorious creep with women you know
these like let me see that's the name a
m
oh
is that the fitness guy i don't know do
you know who he is tony can we pull up a
quick google thing on the camera
put it on my phone my phone's gonna die
um
luckily
she does
i keep
forgetting got two
phones we should this guy i've never
seen him
wait we could put it towards the camera
he looks like he would murder me first
wait who is that i don't know my piece
oh my god everybody's
check my text
guys you know
so
all right
okay see
[ __ ] mary kell
um are you gonna show the camera
yeah i'll show you uh wait he said the
names
uh [ __ ] marry kill the saveo brothers
rocky me mark from left to right okay
okay
i gotta show the camera
should i show this one
hi
my phone's i tried to clean it with a
makeup wipe it's not looking good
okay let me
everybody knows who they are i don't
yeah i've never seen them um i thought
mommy's in the club so i don't know what
any of them talk like so i can't base
this on anything but this picture
but i think it would be mary
f
kill like just based on their faces if
you ever say that you will f by mans
i will be very upset
okay so she said from left to right
right yeah and then it was
yeah mary f k it's just based on like i
think he's the most attractive second
third
okay
okay i like that
truth or dare
truth or dare um
dare
do you have anything on underneath no
oh no i'm kidding
i'm like do you have anything on under
that
okay i dare you
to call
myron right now
you have to i dared you you have his
number i don't and you're gonna
you're gonna say
hey you dropped something your standards
hi i'm pearl
no yeah you have to
have to yeah come on it's fun
oh my god that awkward moment when
oh
you have to
don't [ __ ] out now
but if he doesn't answer then can i
like that i'm cool right
for the meantime somebody will get a
hold of him
someone will get somebody will i'm sure
no way
roloff you're watching this
just do it
he won't answer
that's what people are saying you think
what if he knows already
facetime no no one answers facetime
that's a chicago thing for sure
i forgot five four
three
i don't want to do it
okay if you don't want to that's okay
no i told you you couldn't decline okay
i i
can't even make her take a shot that's
not right okay um
how about how about
um
i don't want to do that that's so
awkward
um okay whoever loses has to promote
each other non-stop for one week okay
like annoyingly i don't mind losing him
this will be fun oh so i'm gonna do them
back to you now so since i chickened out
so it's like okay i get you um truth or
dare
dare
um my phone's gonna die so i'll have to
use yours if you want me to follow
someone
um okay
i
dare you
i'm scared but i'm not scared
like this video if you haven't liked it
yet
i could use my phone if you like need me
to but i just i feel like everything has
to be your phone
i know for the viewers yeah yeah cause
like you don't want to make me get naked
you don't want to do it right i get it
my thoughts exactly
i dare you to post on your story that
that you've had diarrhea for a week
strain
and if i ask if anyone has any tips
[Laughter]
i'm done bye laughs
how do i do it with the street
i'm such a kid
everybody's gonna know i'm [ __ ]
kidding you could have done so much
better
i'll do a lot of [ __ ] final answer yeah
okay
i'm gonna put a filter on though
[Laughter]
guys i've had diarrhea oh
no no it's gotta be a video no not a
video i'm saying like put it as a
as a like a text
so not cool
that's not even fun
what do you mean i think i need
personalities no i'll say it serious
should i go sit on the toilet
yeah you can do it on the toilet
oh my god i do not like that i chickened
out i like
oh my god i do not like that i chickened
out
um
i want to see what
is this a fresh and fit
okay
guys i gotta put good truth or dares in
the chat what nothing